Speaker 1: You know, on this show, sometimes
we'll look at the wacky and zany and kooky
things that right wingers say and will laugh
and will say, Oh, it's so silly and it's so
dumb.
But we don't necessarily always worry for
the future of humanity and the United States
and our legislative bodies on the basis of,
you know, every random thing that Marjorie
Taylor Greene or whoever necessarily says.
I have an example today of something for you.
That does make me really worried about the
future of American democracy, quite frankly,
because of the level of ignorance that it
shows, combined with a sort of brazen confidence.
Despite that ignorance and the reality that
this may be someone who is going to be one
of only 100 senators in the United States.
Herschel Walker is a Trump endorsed Republican
Senate candidate running in the state of Georgia,
and Herschel Walker recently asked, You know,
if there is evolution, if evolution is real
and we humans, Homo sapiens evolved from apes?
Why are there still apes on the planet if
the apes evolved to become humans?
Why are there still apes?
We're going to look at the video in a moment.
There are more than 331 million people in
the United States.
Only 100 at a time get to be members of one
of the most powerful legislative bodies in
the country, the United States Senate.
One of those 100 might be someone who questions
the truth of evolution because there are still
monkeys on planet Earth.
Let's take a look at the clip.
This is this is genuinely depressing.
It really brings me it's I have fear and despair
because of this.
I have no pleasure.
This is not fun here.
Speaker 4: That means somebody up there here
to say, let there be light that Earth started.
And then he had to put someone there on Earth.
Adam was there.
Remember, Adam came there.
The eve came, so somebody had to sort it out.
So that means it had to be a guy who into
some bomb blew up and it started out.
And then I tell you, now
Speaker 1: we're going to get to the really
crazy part.
This idea that listen, if there was some first
human, here's the first human because you
start this bit.
This is not new stuff.
We're treading on very worn ground here.
The idea that you sometimes hear from creationists
is, well, OK.
Listen, I came from a human mother and my
mother came from a human mother, and my grandmother
came from a human mother.
And so if you just follow that at some point
there was the first human mother, and therefore
that person must have been created like that
by a god or higher power.
And of course, when you understand the slow
process of evolution and you understand how
that works, you realize that the premise is
wrong.
It's logical to think if ad infinitum.
It was my mom and her mom and her mom and
her mom and her, and it was just all modern
humans, right?
You might end up saying, Well, I mean, somebody
must have designed and created that first
human, but we understand that that's not the
case.
So this alone, we could spend an hour on.
But let's get to the really wacky part that's
getting a lot of attention
Speaker 4: because I heard I think about this
because at one time the science man came from
Speaker 1: apes.
It's not at one time, but by the way, but
yeah, OK,
Speaker 4: did it not?
I don't go to it every time I read or hear
that, I think to myself, you just didn't read
the same Bible I did.
Well, this was interesting to though.
If that is true, why are there still apes?
Think about, you know, you're too smart.
No, no, no, no.
Think about this, we have an evolution that
is we've gotten so intelligent that if that
is true, why this still leaves and then the
conception of a baby.
Let me tell you, science can't do that.
They still trying to do it, but it can't because
there had to be a god.
So when God came?
Speaker 1: OK, now this is not actually a
crazy question.
I mean, you go, you know, you go to third
or fourth grade when I think that's when kids
start being taught about evolution.
There are lots of curious, naive, wide eyed,
bushy tailed eight and nine year olds who
would say, Hey, but if we came from apes,
why are there still apes?
Didn't the apes become human?
And of course, there is an answer.
Humans did not evolve from a modern living
ape like a modern chimpanzee.
We evolved and descended from a common ancestor
of apes.
We share a common ancestor.
That's the best science we have right now,
which lived and died in the distant past.
And that means we're related to other apes,
and we and those other apes came from an earlier
ape of some kind.
Now that's an eight or nine year old that
would ask that.
Imagine if Herschel Walker becomes a senator.
I mean, really think think, you know, we have
331 million people in this country to pick
from.
Some of them are kids.
So we're not literally OK, but we've got hundreds
of millions of people to choose from.
How do we solve really serious problems in
this country?
Inequality, poverty, education, hunger, climate
change?
When we have a hunt, it's just a hundred people
in the Senate and at least one of them.
There might be others in the Senate who believe
the same stuff.
But when one of your hundred is a senator
saying if evolution is real, why are there
still apes on planet Earth?
How do we solve problems if that's the case?
We can't.
And so when we wonder man, why politics is
so log jammed and we just we're not getting
anywhere and it's these, you know, trivial
arguments about stupid stuff and people getting
fined for not wearing masks and people who
think the vaccines modify.
Or do you how?
We have three hundred and thirty one million
people.
The Senate has 100 members representing those
And a guy who is saying if we if evolution
is real, why are there still monkeys on Earth
has a genuine shot at becoming one of those
hundred and is endorsed by former President
Donald Trump.
It doesn't bode well.
And it is not funny.
It stopped being funny a while ago.